the British Prime Minister faces a
crunch test to her leadership in a few
hours after her own MPs forced the vote
of no-confidence resume we'll know later
tonight whether her party wants her to
go at the weekly Prime Minister's
Questions a little earlier she was again
forced to defend her eleventh hour
postponing of the comments votes on her
beleaguered brexit blood we've had a
meaningful vote we had it in the
referendum on 2000
and if he and if he wants a meaningful
date I'll give him one 29th of March
2019 when we leave
unacceptable
[Applause]
the Prime Minister and the government
have already been found to be in
contempt to Parliament her behavior
today is just contemptuous of this
Parliament
this prime minister can't even do her
own job because of the Tauri Civil War
of this government mr. speaker is an
embarrassment what does the Prime
Minister consider to be most important
playing parliamentary parlor games in
this place or protecting jobs and
businesses by going back to the
negotiating table and thrashing out a
deal that will pass through this house
by pulling the brexit vote the Prime
Minister must now concede that her deal
is doomed the house and her own party
appear to have no confidence in her you
know on an empty house in the seat for
this week's PM Q's well our
correspondent unless you see a chicken
it she is at Westminster as well I can
bring us the latest twists and turns of
the brexit saga pensions certainly have
reached a boiling point here in
Westminster as Theresa May faces the
political crescendo of her leadership
following weeks of speculation that she
might face a vote a new Prime Minister
today that comment the situation is
extremely crucial extremely divisive
certainly seen as one of the deepest
political crises we can have been faced
with in decades and basically what we
have going on as we speak because we
know that 48 required letters have been
submitted to a parliamentary committee
in order to trigger a vote of
no-confidence which will be taking place
later tonight and this will be a secret
ballot cast what's required is a simple
majority 50% plus one Theresa May can
either win or she can lose if she wins
she becomes untouchable for another year
and can all be some stick around and
continue to work on what she is trying
to achieve but if she loses she has to
go and then there will be a leadership
contest wins in the Tory party she would
continue to be a caretaker prime
minister in that time that could be up
until six weeks and certainly creating
more uncertainty in the UK with this
whole brexit chaos and of course earlier
today the House of Commons before the
vote of no-confidence is
is set to take place in the next several
hours as has already been on fire with
Prime Minister Theresa May an opposition
leader Jeremy Corbyn at each other's
throats
can I tell the Prime Minister this sorry
saga is frustrating for businesses for
workers and many actually behind her as
well when is she going to start
listening to people that want actually
to find a constructive solution to this
rather than denying Parliament the right
to debate it and vote on her deal but we
all know one group of people that don't
want to find a constructive solution
it's the Labour Party the Prime Minister
has negotiated her deal she's told us
it's the best and only deal available
there could be no more excuses no more
running away put it before Parliament
and let's have the vote when I say to
the right honourable gentleman that he
should be honest with people he should
be honest with people about his position
he couldn't care less about brexit what
he wants to do is bring down the
government create uncertainty so
division and crash our economy
the biggest threat the biggest threat to
people and to this country isn't leaving
the EU it's a Corbin government
well whether those are some of the last
political flutters Theresa May is going
to be able to experience as British
Prime Minister will be clear in the
hours to come
what is definitely clear at this point
is that Theresa mazey process of working
on brexit because of course she came
into power as Prime Minister shortly
after the brexit referendum it has
really been a nightmare in many
different ways
negotiating the deal that she put
forward done clearly didn't get enough
support at home to talk to European
leaders to try to renegotiate that deal
after obviously not getting her MPs to
back her at home and now faced with this
vote of no-confidence it's definitely
been a nightmare of a process for her
especially given the country is divided
in terms of how brexit should exactly
shape up with so many different opinions
on what exactly it means and how things
should look after it takes place so we
will be seeing later tonight if she gets
to stick around and follow through with
her plans or if she will be shown the
door by her own MPs that will be known
sometime after the vote takes place
that's between 6:00 and 8:00 p.m. London
time and we will find out the results
pretty much right after
you